SHOOTER DRILL COULD BE
TRAUMATIZED SIMPLY BY THE
LANGUAGE.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
THANKS.
THE HEAD OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION SAYS ANTI-GUN FORCES
ARE PLAYING POLITICS WITH LAST
WEEK'S MASSACRE AT THE FLORIDA
HIGH SCHOOL.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY IS AT
THE SIGHT OF THE CONSERVATIVE
POLITICAL ACTION CONFERENCE AT
NATIONAL HARBOR, MARYLAND.
A GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE 11.5 MILES
AWAY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
NRA CEO WHO IS A BIG SUPPORTER
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP DELIVERED
REMARKS ABOUT GUN CONTROL THAT
ARE A WORLD APART FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S PROPOSED FIXES.
>> THEIR SOLUTION IS TO MAKE
YOU, ALL OF YOU, LESS FREE.
>> WAYNE LaPIERRE, CEO OF THE
NRA, DID NOT MINCE WORDS,
WARNING ABOUT WHAT HE SEES AS A
POTENTIAL POST-PARKLAND GUN
GRAB.
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE CALLING FOR A
NEW LIST OF ANYONE, ANYONE WHO
HAS SOUGHT MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO
DENY THEM THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
>> THE NRA SAID PRESENTING
SPONSOR OF CPAC.
IT HAS A HEAVY PRESENCE
THROUGHOUT THE CONVENTION
CENTER.
OFFICIAL SPENT FOR ADVOCATING
FOR STRONGER SECURITY AT SCHOOLS
AND CRITICIZING DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKERS.
>> FOR THEM, IT'S NOT A SAFETY
ISSUE.
IT'S A POLITICAL ISSUE.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT CONTROL AND
MORE OF IT.
THEIR GOAL IS TO ELIMINATE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> THE NEXT SPEAKER WAS
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE WHOSE
PARKLAND RUMORS INCLUDED A
PLEDGE TO COME TOGETHER.
>> LATER THIS WEEK WHEN THE
PRESIDENT MEETS WITH THE
NATION'S GOVERNORS IN OUR
THE SAFETY OF OUR NATION'S
SCHOOLS AND OUR STUDENTS OUR TOP
NATIONAL PRIORITY.
>> PENCE LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR
THE STRATEGY G.O.P. OPERATIVES
TELL FOXES THEIR BEST BET TO
KEEP THE HOUSE: CRITICIZE
NANCY PELOSI.
>> IT WOULD BE A DISASTER FOR
OUR CAUSE OF NANCY PELOSI BECAME
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AGAIN THAT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET IT
HAPPEN.
>> THERE WAS RUSSIA TALK AT
THURSDAY'S SESSION.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE KREMLIN
BEING A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE WERE NO QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S PROBE OR
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DONALD
McGAHN WHO USED PUBLIC REMARKS
TO EXPLAIN HOW HE HELPS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SELECT JUDGES,
AS A RUMORS SWIRL ABOUT A
SUMMERTIME SUPREME COURT
RETIREMENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT LIKES FOLKS WHO
HAVE DEMONSTRATED COURAGE,
ABILITY TO STAND STRONG IN THE
FACE OF ADVERSITY, PEOPLE WHO
KNOW, YOU KNOW THEY WILL NOT
CHANGE AND TURNING TO SOMEONE
ELSE.
>> JUSTICE GORSUCH'S APPOINTMENT
SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY.
REDUCING REGULATIONS, VOWING TO
MOVE THE AMERICAN EMBASSY IN
TOURISM AND REPEALING THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
>> IT LET BILL CLINTON TO CALL
OBAMACARE WHEN THE CRAZIEST
THINGS IN THE WORLD.
THE ONLY TIME I AGREED WITH
BILL CLINTON.
OTHER THAN ABOUT HILLARY.
I'M GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE
ABOUT THEM.
>> CPAC IS NOT JUST SPEECHES IN
A BALLROOM.
THE HALLWAYS ARE ALIGNED WITH
BOOTHS LIKE THIS ONE.
ORGANIZE SAY IT'S ABOUT ACTIVISM
TRAINING AND CAMPAIGN
MANAGEMENT.
THE CROWD APPEARS VERY YOUNG AND